皆さん
春といえばなんでしょう
何でしょう
卒業匠副社長というたまに動画でつ奴が出るんですけどもいい
まあ彼がこの流れから就職が決まって静岡から長野に行くことになりました
農業社会人でございます
ねまた始まってるんですからねでまあ
本当にあいつはね俺がもう同じクラスというか大学も同じ学科で本当に4年間一緒に
過ごしてきた多分一番の友達なんでね
ちょっと卒業式チックなサプライズみたいなやつを
まあ
やって分京王かと思っております最初僕もう
メンバーで youtube をやってて今結局まあ
3人になっちゃったんですけどおいらのチャンネルで2人が来手伝ってくれて言って
下達になってるんですけれども本当に彼には初期の頃から本当にお世話になってたんで
ね
ちょっと空気読んでよこのカメラのと勇気でもうすぐ来るので卒業式サプライズで
ございます
トヨタ邪魔崎からっています
とかそこら辺でいう
わっ
伊予
ああああああああ
ぞ
私と思って
あっっ
ban
によっ
世界さん卒業おめでとうございます
入学してそういうふうにはじめカンパニー入って
久美さんございましたクラー
いわゆるだけてる h 貼るだけで一さんとは違っていつも真面目な手首さんは本当に
素敵でしたーー
雑貨もだけでも違うん a
動画を撮る時とか後大学内ですれ違った時ぐらいしか話せなくてすごく残念でした
そしてはそれもせないのはゴリラドッキーです
例えば真面目なた国タイました芸人をやるとは全然を載せなかったので
門閥引っかかりましたーーー
もう逃げ fc になりそうですかああ
と鮎匠さんにはいつも仲良くしてもらって本当に楽しかったです
4月からはないなので働くということで今度は音がのでああいうことを楽しみにして
ます
からもずっと仲良くしてくださいお仕事にしています
dane
ぷりが募った
ん
2ん
んです
4分
上江洲クラス a 4
はいそうだけ人の出会いは
大学に入学した時ば春
到達がどうぞ一人もいなかった俺にとって初めて知り合った人でした
知っです
拓海は顔が一発です
できて三てっ
すると会社を強くて厳しい人だとさを持っていたのですがまぁえっと
同じ学科で仲良くなってくうちに君のことが少しずつ
わかるようになってきましたし
君はとても真面目でしっかり者
けどその
真面目すぎる性格のせいデー
空部にも高いか出奔したことも分かりましたね
す
君が10年間の中で一番仲が良くて
お熱時間を過ごしたことは間違いないです
多分も例の最初の印象は最悪だったと思います
入学してすぐにバレーボールをゲットして遊んでて
知らないいただければの本ベンチャーへこましてサブ機はスタートです聞いたことです
ね
他に受け流してないことで
主日喧嘩つだと思いましたね
ちょっと授業に踏まずれな俺はいつも市民の脳てあ
レポートを入れてもらったりてやれテスト勉強したことは
う
質はでも覚えています
君には本当に大学では数え切れないほど助けられました
何を張って親友と言えますそして youtube
大学2年生から始めてこれもいろんなことがありましたそれではメンバーで活動して
色々あってメンバーを抜けたり入ったりで最終的には
方法をに1人という形になったけれども
最初から最後まで俺を支えてついてきてくれたのは君一人でした
本当にありがとう
リズム入れ直しますね
は
さで趣味は4月から1人たちです
静岡を出て7件での一人暮らしが始まるわけですし
立派な社会人としてやっていけると思うのですが
寿命真っ直ぐ過ぎるところがあるので
俺は少し失敗だ所があります
その時はん
困った時あったらいつでも相談して切ってください
会社に入るからといって
かけ3副社長ではなく各3枚歳となる佐世はありません
ん
俺たちそして
今度はがを見てくれてるみんなは自民のことを匠副社長として忘れないでしょうし
ずっとこれからも趣味ははじめカンパニーの一位です
社会生活を応援しています
辛くなったり
嫌なことがあったらいつでも
ムードがを見に来てください
youtube で待ってますん
アイゼンは等ございません
配布
あなたはガセ気持ちながらっ
して売れ
これで巧みに入ってるか関係し
じゃあ
翔竿梅雨はい
see
これは別わけねー
どうぞ
だけに輸送
んだった
ございますありがとうございます
あるん
のラーメンですよ
プレゼントプレゼント
me
car
の金は世話になったベンという関数
降ったらです
使ってくださいありがとうございます
これを解決
付けちゃってもいいかもしれないね秋まっすぐんん
あげよーっ
あってると美容師
me
web
水を決行
動画とるとき手塚目とか
0ポート買ったはなかったからです
脱がしたらこれからん
使ってください
ん
しろっ
を防ぐん
4位
これからねぇ
会えることがあってるかもしれないけど
またいつでも一緒に動画太郎
頑張ってせ
ありがとう
ni
それは大
代表はいって本当に1万先生方が思ったよ
理由は決して1週間もそんなないうちにコロニアと思う戻るようになりもう
転がり込むんですね
うって遊び始めてティッシュああああああ
なってないよ頑張るけど
まあ大ウケで一番前が良くなってるだけな俺
当然同じじゃん
どっすら一緒に
唯一ビアろって言ったらいいやサタンあるパスポート2分間揚げますがねぇ
ni
毎日全然つかないという始め何年間も続いてですーっとすぐ
君がとする
4年間この時があったりども dqn
大堤はじめの上について何かしら保存るー
お前一度2
ございません
ますこれからもう
学生としてはうん
ああああああ
2便という可能性
今日は最後に育児
おっん
また遊ぼうねくらいにいうつづり阿蘇
色だよ
というわけでというわけで時に副社長がまあ
は1回じゃないんですけどもひとまず
数足ということで
あなたのステップでさせるかということでございます
俺留年してねーかーな留学してだから市宮だからね以上
時の杉下ああ
こんなへ外れから貰ったのに俺が初めて乗ったろーん
今待つ間だよ
第健康安全好きだからと私です切るねこれ